we're continuing to measure the
destructive impact of that recent
government shutdown on Donald Trump's
approval and it's actually even worse
than I imagined that it would be we saw
Trump's disapproval go up during the
shutdown but we now have a very good new
poll out from the ABC news/washington
post poll inconsolable in donald trump
as in none none at all sixteen percent
say that they have some confidence in
donald trump and just twenty one percent
of the country has a great deal of
confidence in the president this is the
highest percentage two dates from any
time that this poll was done during
trump's presidency for the no confidence
at all results also interesting from
this poll along gender lines maybe not
surprisingly we see this frequently take
place with republicans significantly
higher approval on all questions for
donald trump from men than women whether
it's being a strong leader brings change
has the right personality and
temperament is a dealmaker is honest and
trustworthy understands your problems
overwhelmingly more support from men
than from women reinvigorating the men
going their own way men's rights
activists all right Venn diagram
movement call it what you will
the poll also asked about some specific
policy issues like for example has Trump
met your expectations on a number of
different issues and on no issue did
Trump actually meet voter expectations
check this out we have it on the screen
for our visual audience for only for
dealing with the threat of terrorism
this Trump hit a fifty percent net
positive in terms of meeting people's
expectations where he has exactly a
fifty percent net positive rating on
every other issue a through K the
economy race relations creating jobs
helping the middle class handling the
deficit health care handling
international crises handling issues of
importance to women Supreme Court
appointments border security the
net positive rating is way under 50 in
some cases like with the deficit and
healthcare you do not get numbers this
bad simply with a partisan divide
between Democrats and Republicans okay
these are really genuinely bad numbers
but the most important thing any
opportunity I have to mention this pad
I'm going to mention it you can still
get reelected with these numbers okay
half the country doesn't vote even with
approval in the low-30s you can win if
half the country continues not to vote
it's tougher we've seen presidents be
reelected with approvals in the forties
I don't think we've seen it with
approvals in the 30s but mathematically
it can happen so whenever we see these
results Pat I report on them I tell you
what's going on but if anyone is going
to say clearly this guy's losing in
November 2020 that's the exact opposite
of the attitude that we should be taking
yeah the power of incumbency that's
really strong the last three presidents
got reelected after all and with our
electoral college it's actually possible
for the winning candidate to receive
only 23% of the vote now that's probably
not going to happen because that would
mean that he wins 51 percent of the vote
in a handful of states and then no votes
at all in some other states but just the
fact that that's conceivable makes us
realize that we have a real problem here
and he could get reelected that's
exactly right and that's further
exacerbated by the fact that you can
have very uneven voter turnout because
so many people choose not to vote I
would love to talk to the 21 percent
that have high confidence according to
this poll in Trump's ability to deal
with issues right now like what what
which issues is he doing really well on
and we've had a few of these people call
into the show we say I support Trump and
I say well on what issue do you think
he's doing a good job and they'll name
something and after a couple of probing
questions they immediately fall apart or
go to some other issue so I would really
like to not to convince them to change
their minds but just to understand where
they're coming from I would love to hear
and maybe we will on live calls on the
Friday show hear from some of these
trumpets tell me exactly which issue you
think he's handling competently